hey you guys guess what pain don't hurt
ya subscriber sent us this yes thank you
very much blu-ray Joseph II for sending
us this timeless classic yeah of
American 80s cinema yeah this is up
there with bloodsport I'm trying I'm
looking for a copy of bloodsport
Brad Ness is that the blue razor on it
only from England man they want like 20
bucks for a bloodsport blu-ray that's
not that bad for a Blee right now yeah
but I don't know if I want to see I
don't want to see it that bad I've never
seen it but I've been you know studying
about studying about I think I thought
the Frank Dux it's about the guy you
know there's the fake martial artist but
but yeah this this movie kind of reminds
me of one of those fake martial arts
movies in a way this movie yes in
roadhouse okay so for those of you that
know like those of you they're regular
listeners of the show although I'm a
huge mystery science theater fan you
will also know that Mike Nelson the head
writer for many years on Mystery Science
Theater and now RiffTrax was a huge huge
fan of roadhouse they made so so many
references to it and they even wrote an
original Christmas song on one of their
Christmas episodes that was called let's
have a Patrick Swayze Christmas and it
is delightful it's still a jam I'll tell
you what this is just a was it was an
enjoyable movie to watch it was very
kind of static it was bringing that era
back to me you know but I just was just
kind of amazed of how they tried to take
this premise and sell it to a mainstream
audience yeah I guess I guess it worked
yes it worked it didn't do very well in
the theater but it did really well on
VHS like when it came out later on VHS
and then it has subsequently developed a
humongous cult following so I'm sure
it's probably his money back at this
it's about this skinny scrawny guy who's
supposed to be like it's the best
fighter in the world he's kind of
muscley he's not running no he's not all
right I mean there's there's not a lot
of mass there he
he's tall but still there's there's just
not a lot of mass there to do what it is
he's supposed to be doing and his job
supposed to be the best bouncer in the
world he decided knows how to clear out
any kind of bar and clean up bars and
train your bounce bouncing staff what's
that part I thought was bouncing staff
you're bouncing I thought that part was
kind of realistic that really a really
good bouncer would learn how to train
other bouncers Roadhouse and realistic
or do you thing it I never thought that
I would hear here in sentence but on top
of all this wasn't it convict to uh he
had um okay on somebody but he killed
somebody but he got off because he said
it was self-defense
okay all right now he's got that under
his belt and then on top of that he's a
[ __ ] intellectual yeah he's an
intellectual even doctor women love it
that's a doctor
everybody loves Patrick's yeah in this
movie yeah he can see it's just got so
many tropes what year did this come out
1989 89 okay I thought it might have
been a little bit later I thought I was
like 91 but no that's it's yeah it's got
eight late eighties tropes just well
honestly even though it didn't come out
until the last year of the 80s this is
like the entire 80s distilled into its
purest cinematic form everything 80s is
in this movie yeah it's like there are
there's like corrupt businessmen are the
bad guys yeah there's like [ __ ] bar
fights there's tits yeah where there's
lots of tits and lots of sex now there's
lots of violence yet you know there are
copiously everyone's got a mullet yeah
all the crowds are just people
stereotypes that come straight out of
central casting for white people in bars
yeah it's exactly what also a lot a lot
of homoeroticism yeah that's right there
were a Top Gun I'm gonna say although
that's a pretty close call oh that's a
pretty yeah it's it wasn't obvious in
the day but you look at it now and you
go man that's gay a lot of it wasn't
well I think a lot of people didn't
really get that in you yeah when they
saw Top Gun in the 80s either but it's
like oh is this macho Bru movie when you
say it now you see it now you're like oh
my god you were tall you
just change the soundtrack good
well yeah easily and I'm sure someone's
done it go somebody go check on YouTube
and see if someone's dedicated edit I'm
sure there's more than one yeah but yeah
so the entire premise behind this movie
and it's like like I said and I love
that like Roger Ebert who reviewed this
I read his review it's actually very
funny because you can tell that he
didn't really want to recommend it
because he thought it was a bad movie
and yet he still really liked it and he
was like he's like I'm gonna say things
like all the comedies that he saw the
same week that this came out he's like I
didn't laugh as much at those companies
as I did it this Danny won't because it
it just decided and I'm not sure like
how self-aware it was at the time but I
guess it just decided to go because the
premise is ridiculous the stuff that
happens in it is ridiculous but it leans
into it in a way that it's just like
wildly entertaining to watch I guess it
leans into it it could be that's just
how we're interpreting it I could be
that the directors actually thought this
[ __ ] was was cool it was cool and that
it was realistic it's it's you know what
it's like it's actually like you take
the entire Dukes of Hazzard series and
condense it down sound like that but
then they take you take Patrick Swayze
who was in this era kind of like a
romantic character yeah he had just been
in Dirty Dancing he yes before this and
then you force him into the action role
into the role of an action hero any kind
of pulls it off but not really if you
asked me I mean he just does not come
across as a tough and intimidating
fighter well I guess that's why it
almost kind of seems like in some
reviews I rented this and I guess I
didn't realize it when I was watching it
but they said some the structure of the
movie is very much like either like a
Western or like one of those old like
Roman type of movies yeah we're so like
a kung fu movie yeah we're like somebody
comes into town and it's like it's like
like so Ichi yeah like clears out the
corruption yeah you know fights for the
common man and stuff like that so it's
very similar yeah
so it's not like coming out of left
field you know there it's if you asked
me I mean marketing wise I think it was
miscast all right I think it probably
made the movie would have made more a
lot more sense if this was Sylvester
Stallone playing that role would it
though I don't know he could fold off I
don't know
or maybe Arnold I don't know not on our
no definitely not I guess he couldn't be
in a Western bar it would have to be
semester Stallone I think yeah well
maybe because he can pull it because
he's like a big beefy dude but he could
also pull off like being a smart guy
because he is léa léa so he's a writer
oh yeah he's intelligent guy yeah so
he's not really big though he's kind of
medium ish sighs yeah but I mean you
know big oceans yeah I mean the thing
about mass on him I mean the Patrick
Patrick Swayze I mean he was in he's a
dancer yeah and he looks like a dancer
in this yeah he looks like a dude he's
in good shape yeah yeah he's in good
shape
it looks like a dancer who hit the gym
you know he's dead now him I can't
believe the guy died as young as he did
but yeah cancer and yet she got him and
it back in those days I guess they
couldn't cure whatever kind of cancer it
was that he had but I remember when he
died a surprise meant like that dude
died yeah he was quite young yeah yeah
it looks he looks like he took a dancer
like a ballet dancer and he went into
the gym booked up put about five pounds
maybe five extra pounds on isn't look
bad you know I would say probably I'd
even say that he was probably in better
shape than fried Brussels was crustle
from Escape from New York he seemed a
bit bigger than cross eliminated I'd
have to see them like next to each other
yeah like during that time period cross
over cross all didn't it was a sneaky
though I was kind of a sneaky guy you
know yeah it was not so much to like
happen to be like you know hanging in
combat driving cars and climbing and
chopping and jumping through windows and
doing [ __ ] like that talking talking
like Clint Eastwood and you know seeing
people with a mac-10 crashing cars in
the [ __ ] yeah that's that snake where is
this one and like I said I feel like
this happened in a lot of movies in the
80s and as I said I have to point out
that the director of row
house was actually named rowdy rowdy
Harrington was the guy that's correct in
this movie that's how [ __ ] 80s this
movie is even the director is named
rowdy this seriously this movie I think
kind of inspired a bunch of copies that
movies is centered around bars like
remember coyote ugly and yeah yeah it's
like a spring of these that were like
saloon movies cuz I guess they figured
well a lot of people are hanging out
bars maybe they'd be able to relate to a
bar movie yeah yeah this kinda it
reminds me of my cruise did a bar movie
he did cocktail cocktail yeah yeah that
was like a yuppie bar yeah and it was
like when he didn't like Hawaii or [ __ ]
like it was like it wasn't even an
indoor bar I don't think I don't know
it's been a long time since I seen that
it might I had a feeling it was like out
on the beach or something but I could be
remembering it wrong but the thing about
this one and I think that happens with a
lot of 80s movies and as I said I'm not
sure that in the 80s the people that
were making these movies were entirely
serious I have a hard time believing
that they were entirely serious with
this because okay the whole premise of
the movie is that Patrick Swayze is
lured from New York City where he is a
quote unquote cooler which is like a
like a alpha bouncer like I guess some
kind of uber bouncer like he's over all
the other bouncers and he you know yeah
chill everyone out if you know bouncers
man he just doesn't look the part but
well like I said that's why they gave
him that whole philosophical yeah
Ronan's sort of angle Riesling kind of
anti violence unless he absolutely has
to yeah I think the whole point of his
character was that he was like
struggling because when they've kind of
referred to him killing that dude before
um boy reportedly ripping his throat out
with his bare hands which he does
actually in this movie spoilers later on
in the movie but um I think what they
were getting at was that he was
struggling with the violence within
himself like he didn't want to be like
that and he was like trying to temper it
with like this philosophical Zen kind of
attitude maybe I'm reading too much into
it I think I don't think I think no I
think they were trying to do I think
they were trying to do that I think I
think it was supposed he was supposed to
be a character that tough guys in the
audience could like but then he was also
a sex symbol for the women in the
audience what they were trying like what
a view that I read said in this movie
he's like the perfect man but you know
what I mean it's like he won't get into
a fight like just for stupid reason yeah
but if he has to he will whip someone's
asking rip someone's through it out you
can have you do you can have a beer with
him in the hockey talk bar but then if
you're if you're a female doctor you
date him yeah because he's like tough
and smart yeah and sensitive yeah - so
like a rope like the perfect man but
he's brutal he's not because no check it
out because like I said he was lured
from a bar in New York City where he was
apparently a cooler that was so up that
everybody like already knows who the
[ __ ] guy very bouncer which I've
never heard of that everybody that's
what I mean this is that's why this this
movie's like the premise is ridiculous
and I love it so it's like so everybody
in the country even the like goons that
hang out in this bar is like but [ __ ]
Missouri know who this famous [ __ ]
bouncer is and he's actually on the
second most famous because Wade his
buddy who's played by the [ __ ] always
awesome Sam Elliott and I love him in
this movie and also you get to see his
pubes if you ever wanted to do that yeah
but you made yeah there was one part
where he was showing a scar remember and
like he kind of like and that was like
whoa man I'm not looking for it was
kinda freaky you didn't show like you
couldn't see the balls or nothing but
it's just you know the happy trail as
they would call it have yes I'm sorry
but yeah so so he gets lured from New
York City by this guy who owns this
honky tonk bar in as I said this [ __ ]
nowhere town in Missouri that seems to
only have a bar an auto parts store a
hospital and maybe a couple of houses
and that's about it
that's got this fantastic talky-talk bar
yeah called the Double Deuce or as I
like to affectionately refer to it the
two poops take a cheater so yeah it's
run by Boss Hogg basically run by a Boss
Hogg type figures yeah he's played by
Bengazi on his woman yeah who is like
who's like the the quintessential like
evil businessman even though I mean
really
his whole shtick is that one he
[ __ ] just to be like a petty like ass
handle it's like he'll get in his
[ __ ] helicopter and you know fly
around and like scare all his neighbor's
horses just because he's a dick you know
what I mean like their reason for doing
that really he just does it cause he's
mad because he's so evil you know how to
swimmin in town and it just beats her
and then just punches her in the face
and tells her to turn off her crappy
eighties music yeah yeah yeah she's like
30 years younger than him
now something that I didn't catch cuz
I've seen this at cook two or three
times something that I didn't catch the
first time around is that doc the doctor
lady who's played by Kelly Lynch was
actually supposed to be the villains
ex-wife or ex-girlfriend oh I didn't
catch that
yeah see I didn't catch that until like
the second or third time I watched it
cuz I was just like so because I was
just so blindsided by all the bar
fighting and the titties and yeah and
every end of mullets and everything good
so it's like I wasn't even like listen
yeah as far as fight scenes I mean these
are not fantastic fight scenes you know
they're super well choreographed even
for the day they're just kind of generic
fights if you ask me it's it's just it's
not it's not that kind of an action
movie if I would not call it an attack
at all but it's coming at you like this
is gonna be a nach accent move yeah yeah
I mean but it's never really quite
happens but for some weird reason it
doesn't happen and you don't care you
continue to watch it I don't really know
why I did like the movie I knew I liked
the movie it's it's but I'm kind of mad
at it that I like it because man it's
[ __ ] dumb you know it's second done
well that's why that's why everybody
loves it though because it's just so
dumb and really what is this and
over-the-top dude somebody drives a
[ __ ] literal monster truck yeah
through a car dealership
yeah and crushes everyone about the
station wagons it's like and the bar
fights in this like one review I read of
it though it's like this line crack me
up they said this movie it's like one
third is movie is bar fight it might be
more than that actually yeah but there's
the double dudes at the beginning it's
just like one of those places and I
think these kind of bars like as I grew
up in Daytona Beach were just like full
of
or bars and stuff and it's like this is
one of those bars that only exists in
the movie universe because if you really
owned a bar where this kind of [ __ ] went
on you would lose your ass like inside
of a month nobody we go
well one nobody would go and two you
would spend so much money repairing on
repairing on because the first bar fight
that you see in there pretty much
everybody gets involved in the bar fight
all the furniture is broken all the
glassware is broken several people
appear to be murdered and it's like it's
just like this crazy the cops never come
I guess because the guy like the the
evil corporate guy that owns the town
it's like what he's he's like make such
a big deal about like owning this town
I'm like this town that probably has
like 50 [ __ ] people and I'm like you
big man maybe it has cops at night
coughing and a cop Missouri we're
talking about for [ __ ] sake but yeah
you go in there it's like there's just
this ridiculous ridiculous [ __ ] going on
this bar it's like the [ __ ]
waitresses are selling coke out of the
bathroom that's right it's like they're
not like City problems that's funny yeah
50 people on town it's like a big city
bro every single one of them goes to
this bar and gets in a fight and kill
someone else and no one does anything
about it and it's like it's just like so
so funny and it's just like one of my
one of my favorite scenes and this I
don't remember who's like the first bar
fight scene or the second bar fight
scene there were so many but there was
that whole scene where like the two guys
are sitting at the table and then like
the one like Playmate Playmate of the
Year or whatever she was and then like
the guy who was presumably her husband
or boyfriend or pimp or whatever he was
yeah and he offers the the other guy he
says you can touch her tits or kiss her
tits for $20 yeah and then the guy just
reaches over and starts groping and then
he's like hey man with the fight and
he's like I don't have $20 so it's like
look he just got a [ __ ] freebie and
like everybody seems like totally fine
with this like it's like okay that's all
kinds of [ __ ] that's all kinds of [ __ ]
that doesn't have any bars that's that's
yeah nothing say is that a little
honky-tonk Bar on a middle of nowhere
you know that's experiencing all this
would not have women that look that good
in them no these women are actually you
could immediately tell that they're
Hollywood star
listen that they're you know strippers
and [ __ ] like that these girls really
need to be somewhere like on in a Sunset
Strip or something you know making money
right they're just they're not gonna be
in a little town like that you know you
got a little hot talk manners there's
really nobody under 50 in there yeah
it's like it's older people older people
and like I said it's like older like
biker types and yeah [ __ ] like that if
there's a young woman in there and she's
a crackhead teeth you know so like
that's what I mean that's what's so
[ __ ] funny about this whole movie is
like the whole bar things just like
[ __ ] cracks me up so much so like
Patrick Swayze you know world famous
cooler bouncer is brought to this bar to
clean it up because apparently the guy
that owns it wants to like you know
fancy it up or make it a classier joint
in this tiny little toy it's like who
the [ __ ] is gonna come there oh yeah
but yeah so so all that happens now
Patrick Swayze who's name is Dalton they
don't say if that's his first name or
his last name that's how that's the only
done man thing he's ever referred to in
the movie but he successfully he punches
john doe from x who plays the bartender
i think he's the bartender or one of the
bartenders
he actually punches him in the face and
if you will notice if you watch the
movie in slow motion john doe's nose is
already bloody before Patrick Swayze
it's it so you know I mean that's that's
like some cool like punch and right
there just like you don't even have to
like is just like it goes out ahead like
in a force before the [ __ ] fist even
gets there and gives you a bloody nose
from the other takes it's like oh we
forgot to say yeah yeah so it's like so
he meets the doctor lady when he has to
go to the hospital because he gets
stabbed at some point during one of the
bar fights and uh you know he stitched
up one of his own wounds earlier yeah
like I said what a badass he what and
he's just like not all stoic about it
like here we go see you know that [ __ ]
happens all the time yeah and then he
ends up at the hospital it was fun you
don't have to do that I mean I'm even
more hardcore than that that right there
just do it with tape or you could just
glue it yeah glue it was super glue
super glue works for that you guys
duct tape in fact isn't that I've heard
that that's what super glue was
originally developed for I'd would
closing wound right like quickly I
thought it does work sure I mean
anything that does hold together a drop
super super I mean I did that like one
time because you know as in my in my
career as a graphic designer back in the
old days before we before everything was
computerized when we used to actually
have to cut like pieces and cut links of
type and stuff like that because I used
to work for a newspaper and one time one
morning I guess I wasn't fully awake yet
so I cut off the slice that the sliced
off the tip of my index finger with a
exacto knife when I was a little kid and
I had to I was like maybe like five or
six or something I don't remember
exactly how old it was had a swab I've
got some super glue in my eye oh the
emergency room yeah yeah a doctor went
oh you got superglue in his eye come
over here and they just put he just
dropped something my I would try
eyedropper and he immediately dissolved
it went away huh they already have a
they already have it probably happens
all the time yeah they they already have
an antidote for that that just well
Chris you know and now like instant it
instantly just now I'm curious to know
if any of you guys work in an emergency
room I would love to know the statistics
on how many dudes get drunk and their
friends superglue their dicks to their
legs what that happens yes I beat it
[ __ ] I asked for doing it I'm
just saying I know it's happened more
than once because I've heard stories
jeez I mean there's that kind of stuff
there's also like people putting word
[ __ ] out their butts and stuff like that
what well you put something [ __ ] up in a
man's butt you know well my sister my
sister used to work in billing for like
the intestine fell she she's to see all
kind of stuff she's like you would not
believe this stuff people come in the
hospital with up up their butts lifted
I'm like I wouldn't believe it I believe
it slipped and fell landed on that 13
inch down I don't know how well I
remember one case that happened I think
I've been a priest deferment correctly
but yeah he came in with a big dildo
pizzaz
he said that he was hanging curtains or
changing away I don't know the dildo got
there so many months just left it I
would never leave a dildo in the middle
before that could fall on us hanging the
curtains whatever this is a perfect
position it's like pro tip if you have
to go to the emergency with something
much just tell the truth they know they
are lying they know you lie and they're
good at and and if you just tell the
truth
they're not gonna talk about you and
laugh at you with their friends later on
mate or make up a [ __ ] lie justice
yeah I had this woman over here and you
know the next thing you know they sure
did yeah she pegged me I didn't get
summon sheets that her story then I fell
on a over an arrogant it was rape at
least come up with something that sounds
plausible I owed her money
look she's getting even with me most
people use dildos okay it's like not me
just took a turn okay so yeah so as we
were talking about Roadhouse it like
we're talking about since we were
talking about dildos I was gonna say
this is a rather homoerotic film there's
also but there's something for everybody
like there's naked ladies there's no
naked dudes but mostly if you get to see
Patrick Swayze's but right
I think it's once in this um but you
know there's many many scenes of him
doing Tai Chi without a shirt on and all
this gun [ __ ] so you know if you're into
that kind of stuff then like I said
something for everybody so maybe it's
more of a bisexual movie than a helmet
that I homoerotic I mean I don't I think
he's reading into it I think I think
because of who Patrick Swayze was in
those days okay the audience was gonna
be at least half women well yeah cuz
everything just because of who he was so
they were just trying to appeal they
were trying to make a movie that would
appeal to both men and women yeah trying
to make it and that ends up might mean
looking bisexual yeah that's exactly
what that's exactly the point that's
what happened I don't think they're not
trying to make a bisexual movie though
no I'm not saying they were trying to
but I'm just saying they were trying to
appeal to everybody says like you know
since it's so there's some beefcake in
there for
yeah because you know there's love
scenes and [ __ ] going on in this
focusing in all the man's ass and then
there's also like it hope you have two
titties copious women's titties if
you're in a that kind of thing like I
said there's something for everybody
also if you're into mullets you know
there's some [ __ ] there too yeah another
oh and other funny thing that I have to
point out nothing to do with the Piranha
sysm or anything but one thing I have to
point out this is a bad guy Ben Gazzara
but one of the reasons that you know
that he's a bad guy I mean other than
the thing with his scaring the horses
just to be a douche and everything is
that he has a hunting trophy room yeah
and I think that maybe every species
known to man oh the kitties camera
camera camera like poking out the end of
the desk one who knows why you trying to
move the camera that's gonna fall off of
everything stop push it out of pokey
it's like Oh guys suck she's doing it
she's loving it
she's like no try to push it okay but
yeah so this guy's trophy room I think
Roger Ebert made the joke that it's like
it looks like he went hunting in a zoo
because there's like species in there
that it's like no normal person whatever
hunt is just like it's the weirdest
thing ever as an author officer look at
the kitchen
there's like a triceratops I don't think
there is Sasquatch I don't know and it
wouldn't have separate although that
would have been really really funny and
like they didn't like even focus on it
they just put it there and they do
anything about it now I'm gonna have to
watch the movie again to see if that's
actually and it's not in there cuz that
would be hilarious it's just a bunch of
African game animals I think in and just
random stuff yeah and then there was
like it there's a big polar bear in
there too which actually kind of factors
in later on because one of the henchmen
the polar bear falls on him even though
he clearly had ample time to get out of
the way and I think he had to get the
shot though I and I think that was even
like one of the best one-liners of the
film it's like I got crushed by a polar
bear polar bear fell on me or something
yeah it was like really [ __ ] funny
there's so many [ __ ] good lines in
this and I was gonna say oh and I forgot
to when we were talking about the
homoeroticism there was the whole part
at the end where he was fighting I think
that the henchmans name was Jimmy he was
like the main henchman and during the
fight where Patrick Swayze like tears
his throat I was
hands at the end yeah the thing that
like he's fighting with this guy and
Jimmy gets him up like that like infirm
he's like behind him and then he says I
used to [ __ ] guys like you in prison I
was like that's something that you
really wanted stuff yeah he's trying to
scare him trying to scare his ass i'ma
[ __ ] you I think he said something else
like before like you know yeah something
about something about his ass yeah I
don't know and I was like I was just
kind of laughing at that time that's
what I mean it's a it's a hilarious
hilarious movie I mean it's it's
hilarious everything about it is
hilarious it's entertaining it's not a
good movie no I don't think anyone's
arguing that it's competently shot all
right it does it did have a decent score
music I mean some of the stats and it it
was all competently done that the thing
with it is it didn't really commit any
kind of a genre if you ask me yeah I'm
not sure what genre I would call it like
I guess it usually gets classified as an
action movie but it's not really I mean
there's a lot of fights in it but
there's a lot of other stuff going on in
there too
like I said it almost seems like like a
zato Ichi movie he's like as not to each
movie like the invalid charger you come
to town you meet everybody you see this
[ __ ] up [ __ ] going on you slowly try
to fake resolve the town's problems and
then your well being Zen to say yeah
like you will kick ass if you need to
but you would rather not need to it's
like a lone samurai movies yeah it's
like it's definitely like that which I
didn't really think about it until I was
reading some other reviews I don't like
oh yeah I guess that is exactly what
it's like you which is kind of like a
kind of like a Western yeah but no
gunplay in it well I actually weren't
wasn't there some guys but guys shoot I
think there might have been some guys
well yeah at the end is the very end
yeah oh and I have to say too like when
the when the big businessman gets killed
at the end by all the town's folk and
they just like blow his ass away that
particular scene was inspired by a
real-life murder case which I wrote
about in faceless villain 3 which is
coming out soon the murder of Ken
McElroy which happened is also having a
Missouri
Skidmore Missouri and he was this guy it
happened in 1981 and he was this total
[ __ ] douche nozzle who lived in this
little town and he just like bullied
everybody like he didn't own anything or
not son don't think he was just like
some criminal but um he he just like
bullied everybody and he could do
whatever he wanted because like if
anybody tried to arrest him or anybody
tried to like testify against him he
would kill you or beat the [ __ ] out of
you so he never got arrested for
anything so finally like 4050 people in
this little town were like we're gonna
[ __ ] take care of that dude and he
was at the bar he goes out it's broad
daylight middle of the afternoon there's
like 60 people staying on the street and
they just opened fire and killed his ass
and then like when the police came they
were all like didn't see nothing yeah
and they're still unsolved they still
don't know who shot that guy I mean they
have suspicions because there weren't
that many people in that town um but no
one everybody just stayed totally
tight-lipped cuz everybody hated that
dude so much and he was just like [ __ ]
every I mean he had killed people and
didn't get ya you know caught for it so
that case Ken McKim oh really that was
what that last scene where they killed
the the big bad guy where everybody shot
him and then the cops came were like
what happened even though there's like
dead people everywhere like what is he a
like oh I don't know I don't know what
happened he was dead like they're just
standing there with shotguns now this
movie this movie I think would have been
better they just went ahead and just
committed to making it a male oriented
male audience action film put crustle in
there or you know crustle probably would
have been better in this movie and have
you know intrigued to see what that
would be like you had him do it kind of
like a snake Plissken type character
right and get rid of the most of the
romance edit a lot of that out change
the change the well now you can probably
go that same soundtrack and just go with
more action yeah and get rid of get rid
of or edit the Zen elements of it down
you know and just make it Dahmer
although if you did I liked it more if
you did that it would just be more like
a generic I don't think people would
remember it now it is if you did that
way I don't think they would have been
remembered it no but I don't think it
would have done
better at the box office yeah I mean it
did better later like I said but I think
the reason people remember it is because
of those things that made it different
than your regular action movie and also
the fact that it was completely and
utterly ridiculous yeah you know what I
mean but um I remember when it came out
though
and people seeing it being amused but
not really liking this movie yeah I
didn't see it when could it definitely
got a cult following later this later
we'll begin to appreciate it because
when it came out like I said it didn't
do I don't think it did terrible but it
didn't do that great at the box office
it got nominated for a bunch of like
Razzie Awards yeah
I know stuff like that so it was pretty
critically panned but I think later on
as people began to watch it and could
like appreciate it as just one of those
like so bad it's good type of movies
well it improved with the age I think
because yeah looking back on it you're
looking back into another era of time
yeah with everyone's ridiculous hair
yeah so that element is helping in this
movie when you watch it but at the time
the movie I remember the reaction was
not good to it yeah the women didn't
like this as much as Dirty Dancing that
was all just full blown well that was a
full al romance romance movie and that's
really what the females wanted to see
who saw this movie alright and the guys
who went to go see this was probably
expecting something more along the lines
of a phantom movie yeah alright and they
didn't really get that so it was trying
to play it safe and go down the middle
and from what I remember that did not
get a very good reaction from the
audience like I said it didn't do well
at the box office yeah which you know
money talks and [ __ ] walks and at
the time this just wasn't appreciated I
remember just kind of came and went real
quick yeah oh my god goofing on it yeah
it was one like I said I think in
hindsight it's a lot better it stands
out a lot more bazan yeah because in the
80s I mean they were I don't even know
there were lots of there was just
countless countless like action movies
and a lot of them were like really
generic and really forgotten yeah so I
think the reason this stands out is
because it was doing something a little
bit different and also just because of
the complete and utter
you listener but even though a lot of
80s action movies are kind of ridiculous
in the same sort of way but are we good
man yeah well I know that well that's
why they were good yeah that's why the
hurricane guy can watch I like
ridiculous I can watch commando a
[ __ ] you know once a week I've seen
some people compare this to commando in
the same way they'd have a same compound
it has that same kind of tone to it well
it's just kind of like over the top and
it doesn't even give a [ __ ] you know
what I mean yeah commando doesn't have
any real slow spots in it per se it's
that linear this one has romance scenes
and [ __ ] and they doesn't really have
they don't really have that it no
commando didn't have that at all radon
Shawn was in there but there was no
romantic scene yeah I barely remember
her in it yeah I mean she was didn't so
you have a few so you could have a woman
in the movie yeah yeah here we go we'll
just butter yeah can we just put a
cardboard cutout of a woman in movies
would you have to have an actual woman
doing it's like they're all the men were
then we're also just a means to an end
also yeah I mean know all that all the
male actors were just a means to an end
well yeah it was action movies were
about watching our swords negative it's
a [ __ ] bunch of people out and
shooting watching people and shooting
people yeah yeah I mean you know yeah
he's gonna save his daughter yeah I'm
trying to think of some other let's see
what other trivia was I gonna mention on
this oh the the band that plays in it I
mean obviously a lot of the music and
the band that's in there like behind
[ __ ] a wire mesh fence or plexiglass
or whatever it is that's the Jeff Healey
band and he is an actual Canadian
musician I think he might have passed
away now but I don't really want to say
that definitively because I'm not really
sure but he is actually blind he didn't
Tom didn't know that but I do when we
watch the movie but yeah so he was in
this he actually was pretty good in it
but there was also a band at the
beginning and it was actually the
cruzados and I don't know if it was the
whole band or I think just the singer of
the cruzados that he was also in the
band that was in from dusk till dawn
yeah you know I mean yeah I thought he
looked familiar and then I was like oh
yeah he was in that Tarantino all the
band members and all the musical acts
and everything musical numbers in the
movie were kind of the attempt to make
this movie really cool and relevant for
its time yeah yeah it came off as kind
of lame I think it would come off as
lame and generic even back then if you
looked at the the people in the audience
in the crowd the bar crowd itself you
could tell that they were not wearing
their own clothes yeah it all looks fake
everybody a costume like that happened a
lot in 80s movies especially movies
about quote-unquote gangs like yeah like
ones inspired by the Warriors yeah it's
like absolutely those are not I mean
those are obviously costumes right those
are not their real clothes everything's
brand-new
yeah okay everything is brand-new
everything is you could tell was put
together pretty quickly by somebody out
in wardrobe
yeah you can you know decide here this
looks kind of punk rock but yeah yeah
but that added to the tone of love yeah
we're gonna have to do like a whole I
want to do like a whole show about yeah
punk rockers as villains and 80s like to
look right you had to know what you were
doing and then vary the tone had to be
very uniform if the clothes are all
brand new the cars have to all be brand
new
the interiors have to all be brand new
or it just looks unrealistic why are all
these people in brand-new clothes that a
used environment yeah you know in these
old cars it doesn't look right it looks
fake to me but you know and another
thing too it's like if you're in some
badass gang even if you're like you know
say robbing and killing people for money
or selling drugs or whatever you're not
gonna like use that money for new
clothes you know you're not gonna head
down to the Macy's and like buy some new
gang clothes you're gonna buy drugs yeah
yeah they just don't did never look like
the thugs that they were supposed to be
well and I mean me you know me and and
you to to a lesser extent but I mean you
know growing up sort of in the punk-rock
goth community like in the 80s it's like
we just thought that was so funny
because they just never got it right no
I mean no but I didn't know anybody that
little I always have to look wrong now I
should note too that I that I didn't
even know this but Road house had a
sequel that came out what a sequel to
this 2006 it came out direct-to-dvd Jake
[ __ ] Butte it was in it he was the
villain but other than it didn't have
anybody like from the original cast it's
like they mentioned Dalton you know
Patrick Swayze's character but they only
mentioned him to say that oh he got shot
before the movie started and this is
supposed to be like his son okay
and I think that the plot was pretty
similar like you know what I mean but
I've never seen it but if any of you
have seen it please tell me because it
sounds kind of like a Chevy van it
sounds delightful
also Lucy's your draw he's a bad guy
he's the he's the heavy he just goes
like that with his teeth and everybody
just went keels over although I like a
Miss right nurse that is awesome if
writers I kind of love Jake Busey well I
love Gary because it wasn't Jake Busey
in gnocchi's at the side of the earth I
think he was oh yeah I think he was he
might have been now that you mention it
yeah I know I like that too that is it
is it on Netflix oh I don't know I got
it all wrong I know it's on one of those
one of those things blu-ray
that's right I forgot all about that
that you had bought that yeah here is
and here is my very favorite very
favorite piece of trooper trivia about
rodell's which I got from the Wikipedia
page and I didn't know this either so in
2003 somebody actually made an
off-broadway musical of Roadhouse and
the best thing it they did it as a
comedy and the best thing about it is
the title and this is the title you guys
Roadhouse the stage version of the
cinema classic that starred Patrick
Swayze except this one stars tymek from
the 80s cult classic the last dragon
wearing a blond mullet wig damn that's
the title I'm like that makes me so
happy and the last bit of trivia was
that apparently they were actually
talking about remaking this because you
know every movie gets around to somebody
talking about remaking it somewhere at
some time so in 2015 they were talking
about remaking this with Ronda Rousey as
the lead as I guess she was supposed to
be a bouncer or whatever and Nick
Cassavetes was going to direct it but
apparently it didn't
they did they talked about it for about
a year and then it all fell through so I
guess they're not gonna do it now
although I imagine like I said they'll
get around to it some brother because
they get away with a remake in every
other movie so you know yeah well that
was Road house it is a watch please
seriously go on YouTube it's probably on
YouTube I'm sure and go look up mst3k
let's have for Patrick Swayze Christmas
it's there beautiful it's actually a
very nice Christmas song and and they
read a whole and the whole Christmas
songs let's have a Patrick Swayze
Christmas is all about Roadhouse and it
is very very funny and I play it every
Christmas because I watched that mst3k
that's the tube Christmas episodes I
watched his every Christmas alright so
hope you enjoyed this breakdown of
Roadhouse thank you very much Joseph for
sending us the blu-ray we really did
enjoy it with much liquor like we use it
well I was you as usual it's not a bad
movie it's it's it's an amusing movie of
its era that it actually kind of got
better with age
yeah because of its [ __ ] ludicrous it
is it that's why it's great because it's
weird read it it does it does have some
testosterone-filled moments you never
made like it is not PC at all
I like its kind of wrap that for me that
was refreshing because the in in the
modern meet to era this comes off as a
pretty sex system from what I remember
it is not very sexy but it's funny it is
it is like I said a lot of movies kind
of like that man I mean you know the
times yeah exactly the times and nobody
took it seriously back then either I was
there yeah well that that it back then
yeah because it's just a stupid I mean
it's just silly yes yeah anyway so
remember if you enjoy the show I guess
we're not gonna do all the plug at the
end but you know go to our patreon page
yeah go to our blog 13 o'clock podcasts
out WordPress yeah I liked the video
like the video like share subscribe do
all the stuff that you normally do and
we will see you next time bye